네, 안녕하세요. 오늘은 만기 때
재계약서를 쓰자라는 주제로 강의를 할
건데 이때 재계약사 안 쓰면은
임대인한테 무조건 분리합니다. 그래서
그 분리한 이유가 뭔지 오늘 좀
설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다. [음악]
어, 일단 계약서를 안 쓰면은 자동
연장된 것으로 봐요. 그래서 동일한
조건으로 연장된 것으로 보긴 하는데
그거를 용어로 묵시적 갱신이라고
합니다. 근데 문제는 [음악] 뭐냐면
묵시적 갱신이 된 상태에서는 임차인은
언제든지 해지 통고를 할 수 있어요.
그래서 갑자기 묵시적 갱신을 해서
나는 자동으로 1년 연장된 줄
알았는데 임차인이 갑자기 다음 달에
나갈래요 하면은 3개월 뒤에 효력이
발생돼요. 그래서 임대인 입장에서는
굉장히 불리해집니다. 그래서 보증금도
마련해 줘야 되는 부분도 있고 그리고
임대료가 높은 임차인 그러니까 상가
임대차보 해당이 안 되는 임차인은
폐지 통고를 하면 한 달 뒤에 효력이
발생돼요. 그래서 물론 그때는
임대인도 언제든지 해지 통과를 할 수
있지만 임대인은 6개월 뒤에 효력이
발생되거든요. 그리고 재계약서를 쓸
때 좋은 점은 뭐냐면 기간의 구속력이
생겨요. 그래서 재계약서를 쓸 때
>> [음악]
>> 뭐 1년이 됐든 2년이 됐든 3년이
됐든이 기간의 구속력이 생깁니다.
그리고 임대료를 협상해야 되는 부분도
생겨요. 그래서 상가 임대차 보호법에
적용이 되면 5% 이내에 협상을
하잖아요. 그래서 1년씩 계약하고
계속 5%씩 올릴 [음악] 수도
있어요. 그래서 임대료 협상의 이런
부분이 생길 수 있습니다. 근데
문제는이 상가 임대차 보호법에 적용을
안 받는 [음악] 임차인은 임대료의
상한성이 없습니다. 그래서 요때 이제
주변 시세에 맞게 이렇게 올려받는
경우도 있는데 근데 만약에 과도하게
높을 경우에는 뭐 소송하는 경우도
있어요. 그래서 감정을 받아서 어
이렇게 임대료를 측정하는 [음악]
경우도 있습니다. 그리고 보통 재계약
썼을 때 특약을 추가하는 경우가
많아요. [음악] 이때 뭐
관리비라든지 뭐 기타 등등 내용들
그리고 주차라든지 이런 특약 내용을
추가하는 부분도 [음악] 있기 때문에
임대인 입장에서는 재계약시에 무조건
재계약서를 쓰셔야 됩니다. 무조건
분리해요. 그래서 재계약서를 반드시
쓰셔야 되고 그냥 안 하고 묵시적
갱신되는 경우가 진짜 제가 봤을 때
과반수 이상해요. 네. 그래서 그냥
냅둔 경우가 되게 많은데 어 이런
부분도 있으니까 여러분들이 요런
부분도 기억하시면 좋을 것 같습니다.
>> 계약서를 이제 보통 연말에 쓰는데
12월 뭐 30일이나 30일 정도
쓰는데 계약서에는 31일 계약서를
쓰고 연말이 너무 바빠서 다음에 1월
초에 가서 쓰는 건 상관이 없나요?
만기 6개월에서 1개월 이내에 얘기를
안 하면 묵시적 갱신이 된 것으로
봐요. 예. 그래서 만약에 다음에
쓴다 그러면 묵시적 갱신이 된 거죠.
이미
>> 권리금 주장은 어쨌든 그 계약 기관
동안만 할 수 있는 거고 권래금
주장은 주인한테 할 수 없는
거거든요.
>> 그렇죠. 그죠. 주인한테 할 순 없는
거고 임차인들끼리 이제 알아서 하는
거고 근데 이제 임대인이 방해해서 안
돼요. 방해해도 되는 부분들이
있어요. 예를 들어서 뭐 새로운
임차인이 뭐 임대료를 부담할 수 없는
임차인이라든지 아니면 임대료가 민합돼
있다라든지 재건축 뭐 이런 대수선을
미리 사전에 통보하고 뭐 한
경우라든지 등등 이제 법 조항들이 좀
있거든요. 그래서 그거 해당되지
않으면은 임대인은 임차인이 권리금
회수 기회를 방해하지 못합니다.
그리고 하나 또 보게이 사람은 계약이
다 끝났어요. 그 사람을 이제
인대로도 밀리고 해서 내용 질명을 막
보내서 어쨌든 내보냈어요. 근데 그
사람 물건이 코스라인이 남아
있잖아요. 그걸 저희가 치우려고
했더니도 안 된대요.
>> 맞아. 맞아요. 그거는 절대 치우면
안 돼요. 그거는 거의 형사
처벌감이어서 그거는 그 보관하는데
보관하면 되거든요.
>> 그것도 어쨌든 그 사람이 해야 되는
말이에요.
>> 근데 그 사람이 안 하겠죠. 네.
>> 저희가 어저께도 강제집행을 하나
했거든요. 임차인이 물건이 되게
많았는데 [음악] 그거를 그 강제
집행관이 와가지고 그거를 다 거기
보관하는 데에다가 납둬요. 물론 이제
보관료가 발생된다라든지 그런게 좀
되긴 하지만 그래서 임차인한테
조심해야 될게 뭐냐면 임대료 안
낸다고 갑자기 막 집 비닐번호로
바꾼다든지 아니면 참가에 있는
물건들을 그냥 막 폐기 처분하는 경우
되게 많거든요. 그래서 요거는
인베인한테 굉장히 불리합니다.
합법적인 절차를 통해서 그냥 보관소에
맡겨 놓는 거를 좀 거해 드리고
있습니다. 네. 그래서 제가 일단은
좀 임대인한테 꼭 필요한 재계약서
쓰는 거를 좀 말씀드렸고 이렇게 뭐
법적으로 다른 거는 좀 되게 오랜만인
거 같아요. 그래서 만약에 여러분들
좀 궁금한 거 있으시면 댓글 남겨
주시면 언제든지 제가 참고해 가지고
좀 이렇게 다시 한번 또 촬영을 해
보도록 하겠습니다. 네. 그리고 여기
뒤에 있는 제 책이 나왔습니다. 네.
그래서이 내용도 좀 담겨 있어요.
빌딩 투자에 궁금한 거 있으시면이
책을 봐 주시면 너무 감사드릴 거
같고요. 네. 그래서 오늘 제가
말씀드렸는데 좀 정리를 해 볼게요.
그래서 묵시적 갱신 그러니까 자동
연장이 된 경우에는 [음악] 그
동일한 조건으로 계약한 것으로 보지만
이때 핵심은 뭐냐면 임차에는 언제든지
해지 통고를 할 수 [음악]
있습니다. 그래서 3개월 뒤에 효력이
발생될 수 있고 1개월 뒤에 효력이
발생될 수 있기 때문에 임대인
입장에서는 무조건 계약서를 쓰셔야
돼요. 네. 재계약서를 반드시 쓰셔야
된다라는 거 여러분들 기억하시면 좋을
것 같습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다.